معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
اطلعنا على تطورات ساعات الصباح الاولى
كيف
تبد هي كالعاده استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي
في انحاء مختلفه من قطاع غزه وربما عاشت
مناطق مختلفه من القطاع غارات اسرائيليه
وليله داميه من جراء استمرار هذه الغارات
واستمرار القصف المدفعي على انحاء مختلفه
ربما خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه يستمر فيها
القصف العنيف وايضا المناطق الوسطى في
خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه المناطق الوسطى
المناطق الشرقيه الجنوبيه لا سما منطقه
جورت اللوت ومنطقه قيزان النجار هما
المنطقتين الاساسيتين
حديثتين في عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي
المدفعي لا سيما بعد توغل الدبابات
الاسرائيليه من هذه المناطق و تمركزها
وتموضع ومحاصر السكان و سيما النازحين
الذين كانوا يتواجدون في مدارس تابعه
لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الانرو وايضا
مدارس عامه وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي كان
يتمحور ويتمركز في تلك النقاط احزمه ناريه
شنتها ايضا الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
على خانيونس لم يعرف بعد طبيعه الاهداف
التي استهدفتها هل هي بنن تحتيه وشوارع
كما هي العاده ام ان هناك منازل وقعت في
عفوا وقعت في اطار هذه الاحزمه وبالتالي
دمرت وسويت بالارض ايضا القصف المدفعي
والغارات الاسرائيليه ما زالت
متواصله عفوا في المناطق الشرقيه لخان
يونس بن سهيلا وخزاعه والقرار وعبس وهذه
المناطق ما زالت ايضا تتعرض الى قصف مدفعي
وغارات اسرائيليه لكن حتى الان منذ عده
اسابيع لم تستطع طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني التوجه الى تلك المناطق
وبالتالي معرفه ما الذي جرى في تلك
المناطق حجم الدمار والضرر من جراء
استمرار هذه الغارات و استهداف الجيش
الاسرائيلي لهذه المناطق والتركيز عليها
منذ عده اسابيع ايضا دير البلح وهي
المنطقه التي يطلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
سكان قطاع غزه او من سكان على وجه الخصوص
مناطق وسط قطاع غزه ان توجهوا اليها لا
سما المناطق الغربيه هذه المناطق تعرضت
بالامس الى غارات عنيفه استهدفت على الاقل
منزلين منطقه في منزل واحد في منطقه حكر
الجامع
وايضا المنزل الاخر في المناطق غربيه لدير
البلح وهناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى نقلوا
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في وسط القطاع
هذا المستشفى هو المستشفى الوحيد في وسط
القطاع والذي ما زال محاصرا بفعل استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي على الشوارع الرئيسيه
المؤديه الى هذا المستشفى ايضا هناك قناصه
يعتلون بعض المباني المرتفعه على اطراف
مخيم المغازي ويطلقون النار على مداخل هذا
المستشفى بالاضافه الى تحليق طائرات كواد
كابتر
اسرائيليه في سماء هذا المستشفى وهناك
تحذير شديد من قبل وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
بان اعداد الشهداء واعداد الاصابات سترتفع
ارتفاعا ملحوظا اذا استمر هذا المحاصره
اذا استمر هذا الحصار على هذا المستشفى لا
سما وانه المستشفى الوحيد في وسط القطاع
الذي يقدم الاسعافات الاوليه والرعايه
الصحيه لسكان وسط قطاع غزه باكمله
وبالتالي الاصابات والشهداء سيبقون في
الشوارع اذا خرج هذا المستشفى عن الخدمه
القصف الاسرائيلي ايضا ما زال مستمر في
المناطق الشرقيه لشارع صلاح الدين مخيم
المغازي مخيم البريج وايضا قريه المصدر
وتعرضت هذهه المناطق الثلاثه الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وايضا الغارات
الاسرائيليه مكثفه وتستهدف في مخيم
المغازي على وجه الخصوص مربعات سكنيه
ابيدت ومسحت عن الخارطه ومنازل بالتالي
العشرات من المنازل دمرت من جراء استمرار
هذه الغارات ايضا القصف المد دفعي مستمر
في مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج وكذلك مخيم
النصيرات الذي يتعرض الى قصف عنيف لا سما
منطقه شارع العشرين ما بين منطقه شارع
العشرين وشارع صلاح الدين وهذه المنطقه
بات القصف فيها مركز وبحسب شهود العيان
هناك شهداء ما زالوا على الارض منذ عده
ايام لم تستطع طواقم الاسعاف الوصول اليهم
بفعل القصف الاسرائيلي الذي لم يتوقف ولا
لحظه واحده من قبل الاليات والدبابات
الاسرائيليه ايضا المناطق الشماليه لمخيم
النصيرات تتعرض في كل لحظه وفي كل حين الى
قصف اسرائيلي لكن منذ عده ايام ايضا القصف
مستمر في مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع والغارات
الاسرائيليه لا تتوقف ما بين فين واخرى
ربما هي ليست بشده الغارات التي باتت
تشهدها مناطق خانيونس ومناطق دير البلح
وال المخيمات في وسط القطاع لكن هناك
غارات متفرقه تستهدف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
وهذه الغارات مركزه على هذه المنازل من زل
في جباليا في شمال القطاع وبالامس كان
هناك عده منازل في مدينه غزه وبالتالي
الجيش الاسرائيلي بات في على ما يبدو انه
انتقل الى المرحله الثالثه في مدينه غزه
وشمال القطاع على وجه الخصوص ويركز من
خلال استهدافه ل في قصف هذه المنازل
المدنيه وبالتاكيد عندما نتحدث عن مدينه
غزه وشمال القطاع نحن نتحدث عن عدد قليل
من المنازل اصلا الذي ما زال متواجدا بسبب
القصف الاسرائيلي والدمار الهائل في
الاحياء السكنيه في مدينه غزه وشمال
القطاع و بالتالي المنازل المتواجده والتي
ظلت قائمه وان كان جزء منها مدمر هناك
عشرات بل مئات من الناس والافراد يسكنون
فيها مع بعضهم البعض وبالتالي اي غاره
اسرائيليه على تلك المناطق هناك عشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى لكن حتى خدمات الاسعاف
وخدمات الرعايه الصحيه والمستشفيات جميعها
متعطله بعد ان خرجت اغلب مستشفيات مدينه
غزه وشمال القطاع عن الخدمه بفعل القصف
الاسرائيلي القصف ايضا ممتد حتى الى رفح
الى هنا الى جنوب قطاع غزه حيث المنطقه
التي يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انها امنه
وبالتحديد في حيت تل السلطان في رفح حيث
قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي عدد من الشقق
السكنيه في مدينه رفح وكان هناك 15 شهيدا
جراء هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه العنيفه على
هذا المنزل في حي تل السلطان حي تل
السلطان يقع في غرب مدينه رفح هو من
المناطق الاكثر اكتظاظا بالسكان ب
والنازحين في حتى في مدينه رفح رغم ان
مدينه رفح جميعها مكتظه لكن حي تل السلطان
هو الاكثر اكتظاظا وبالتالي القصف بكل
تاكيد اي غاره اسرائيليه على هذا الحي
توقع عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى وكان
اغلبهم اطفال لان في هذه الساعه المتاخره
بكل بكل تاكيد يكون النساء والاطفال في
المنزل والرجال يتركون المنازل للنساء
والاطفال في العاده كما جرت العاده في
قطاع غزه وفي انحاء مختلفه وبالتالي هو
قصف اسرائيلي عنيف على كافه محافظات قطاع
غزه والقصف المدفعي ايضا مستمر على كافه
المناطق الوسطى شكرا جزيلا لك هشام زقوت
مراسلنا من
رفح